HELPED PRESERVE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY ON JANUARY 6th AND THE
DAYS LEADING UP TO IT.
WHILE YOU WERE WATCHING
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE HOUSE
WRAPPED UP ITS 13th VOTE.
BALLOT NUMBER 13, AND THEY,
AGAIN, DID NOT ELECT A SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
NO ONE GOT ENOUGH VOTES.
RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE ALL VOTING
ON A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
THAT IS -- THAT'S THE MOTION
RIGHT NOW BEING VOTED ON.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO CNN'S MANU
RAJU.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THE MATH AND
IT SEEMS LIKE THE TASK WILL BE
MUCH EASIER FOR KEVIN McCARTHY
TO BECOME THE SPEAKER IF THESE
TWO HOUSE REPUBLICANS BUCK AND
HUNT WHO ARE ABSENT RIGHT NOW
FOR PERSONAL REASONS, IF THEY
RETURN.
TELL US WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Reporter: THIS IS EXACTLY WHY
THE HOUSE IS VOTING TO ADJOURN
RIGHT NOW, TO GIVE TIME FOR
THOSE MEMBERS TO RETURN.
BUCK HAS A FLIGHT ARRIVING BACK
INTO WASHINGTON AROUND 9:00 P.M.
THEY PLAN TO COME BACK AT 10:00
P.M.
THAT WOULD GIVE KEVIN McCAR THIR
TWO ADDITIONAL VOTES.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE WILL GET
THERE.
THERE'S ALREADY A FURIOUS EFFORT
UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW TO GET THE
OTHER REMAINING HOLDOUTS.
THE TWO MOST VIEWED AS GETTABLE
IS MATT ROSENDALE AND ELIJAH
CRANE.
BOTH OF THEM ARE UNDER -- BEING
LOBBIED BY THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE
TOP LEADERS TO BREAK RANKS, AND
I'M TOLD THAT THE CONCERNS ARE
POLITICAL.
CRANE IN PARTICULAR IS CONCERNED
THAT IF HE BACKS McCARTHY THIS
COULD HURT HIM IN A POTENTIAL
PRIMARY BID.
MR. McCARTHY, DO YOU THINK YOU
HAVE THE VOTES TO BE ELECTED
SPEAKER TONIGHT?
>> YES.
>> YOU DO?
>> YOU'LL BE ABLE TO FLIP
ROSENDALE AND CRANE?
>> I'LL HAVE THE VOTES.
>> WHAT WERE THEIR CONCERNS?
WELL, THERE YOU HAVE IT.
HE SAID, YES HE'S GOT THE VOTES
TO BECOME ELECTED SPEAKER IF YOU
ARE STILL WITH ME HERE, JAKE.
>> YEP.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS HE HAS THE
VOTES TO BE ELECTED SPEAKER.
THAT IS NEWS.
HE HAS NOT BEEN SAYING THAT SO
FAR.
IN FACT, FOR SOME TIME, KEVIN
McCARTHY HAS BEEN SAYING THAT
IT'S UNCLEAR WHEN HE WOULD BE
ELECTED SPEAKER.
THERE'S NO TIME FRAME.
THAT'S WHEN HE SAID LAST NIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID THIS
MORNING.
NOW YOU HAVE KEVIN McCARTHY
SAYING THAT TONIGHT HE WILL HAVE
THE VOTES TO BE ELECTED SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, AND THAT WOULD
MEAN THAT YOU HAVE TO FLIP SOME
MEMBERS SOMEHOW, SOMEWAY.
THOSE REMAINING HOLDOUTS, ELIJAH
CRANE AS WELL AS MATT ROSENDALE
OF MONTANA.
BOTH HAD EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE POLITICS OF SUPPORTING
McCARTHY.
CRANE OF POTENTIAL PRIMARY
IMPACTS HE COULD HAVE.
ROSENDALE IS EYEING A POTENTIAL
SENATE RUN IN MONTANA.
HE WANTS TO STAY TO THE RIGHT IN
ANY POTENTIAL OPPONENT THERE.
ONE MONTANA OPPONENT, RYAN
ZINKE, ALSO SUPPORTING McCARTHY.
YOU GET THE SENSE OF THE
POLITICS THERE, BUT McCARTHY
DOESN'T SEEM TOO CONCERNED.
I ASKED HIM ABOUT ROSENDALE AND
CRANE, AND HE DIDN'T QUITE SAY
HOW HE PLANS TO GET THOSE
MEMBERS, BUT THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS IN WHICH YOU
CAN GET SOME.
SOME MAY VOTE PRESENT TO LOWER
THE VOTING THRESHOLD, AND THESE
TWO TO SUPPORT McCARTHY ARE
ESSENTIAL.
THIS IS AN HISTORIC SPEAKER'S
RACE.
MORE THAN 100 YEARS HERE THAT HE
WILL FINALLY GET THE VOTES TO BE
ELECTED SPEAKER AFTER WE'VE SEEN
IT'S BEEN 100 YEARS SINCE WE
HAVE HAD MULTIPLE BALLBALLOTS.
>> IT IS HUGE NEWS AND A LUCKY
FRIDAY THE 13th FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY AS OF RIGHT NOW.
NOT JUST LUCK, BUT OBVIOUSLY A
LOT OF WHEELING AND DEALING AND
NEGOTIATING.
RIGHT NOW, KEVIN McCARTHY IS
WITHIN GRASP OF THE HOUS